bonjour je m'appelle catherine girard je
suis étudiante au doctorat en sciences
biologiques de l'université de montréal
on s'est peut-être déjà dit qu'elle
mangeait trop de poisson peut être
mauvais pour vous et la cause de ça
c'est le mercure le mercure c'est un
contaminant qui peut se retrouver dans
la charte du poisson effectivement si on
en mange tout devient dangereux pour
notre santé
par contre je sais pas pour vous mais
moi j'aime seul poisson parce qu'on
devrait continuer à manger
vu le risque qui est posée par le
mercure et je rassure tout de suite la
réponse à cette question c'est oui parce
que le poisson c'est très bon pour la
santé
ces riches en vitamines en minéraux en
oméga 3 c'est vraiment une source de
protéines d'excellente qualité
en plus de ce faux plombier le fait que
beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde on va
dépendre pas même plus la consommation
de poissons que nitia montréal
si on réfléchit par exemple aux villes
côtières ou communautés autochtones ou
la pêche qui représente un pilier dans
la diète mais dans ces endroits là la
question du mercure ça devient une
question qui est très importante au
niveau de la santé donc qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire si on veut pouvoir se
protéger du mercure et de ses effets sur
notre santé
sans se priver de manger du poisson qui
est très bon pour nous mais pendant mon
doctorat
j'essaie de trouver des méthodes que les
consommateurs pourraient utiliser pour
diminuer la quantité de mercure qu'ils
absorbent de leur nourriture
donc je travaille en laboratoire où je
stimule la digestion qui se passe dans
le corps humain avec des produits
chimiques dans des éprouvettes
j'essaie de lutte anti les approches
comprendre dans notre cuisine en
préparant le repas pour nous protéger du
mercure j'ai trouvé par exemple que la
cuisson savoir un effet qui est très
important donc si j'ai un filet de
poisson etc avant de le manger je le
fais cuire
je vais absorbé seulement le tiers du
mercure que jacques sombret du même
phyllis je n'ai mangé cru la raison pour
laquelle on voit cette dimension là
c'est que lorsqu'on fait cuire la viande
les températures élevées vont faire en
sorte que les protéines dans la charte
du poisson on se replie autour du
mercure comme une cage tout ça
m'empêchait de mercure d'être absorbée
par le corps il va être éliminé avec les
seuls par contre si vous êtes curieux
vous aimez pas le poisson cuit vous
préférez le poisson cru les sushis les
tartares j'ai une autre solution à vous
proposer
pendant mes recherches j'ai trouvé que
le thé qu'on achète en magasin ils
contiennent des molécules qui peut lier
mercure très très fort comme un élément
ce lien ne va empêcher une partie du
mercure d'être absorbée par le corps
donc si j'ai un morceau de poisson et
qu'en mangeant le bois une tasse de thé
j'absorbe et seulement la moitié du
mercure que jacques sombret si je
mangeais le même poisson sans monter
donc ça peut être une autre façon de se
protéger
évidemment les résultats dont je parle
aujourd'hui ont été testés en
laboratoire on doit encore les tester
les valider chez des êtres humains mais
ça ne démontre qu'on est sur des pistes
très intéressantes pour offrir les
outils aux consommateurs
pour qu'ils puissent se protéger du
mercure sans se priver de manger du
poisson qui est très bon pour la santé
mais là pour terminer si vous me dites
que vous n'aimez pas le poisson cuit
vous n'aimez pas été non plus vous
voulez pouvoir protéger toutes mercure
ne perdez pas espoir j'ai une dernière
solution avait proposé pendant la taille
monde acteurs âgés c'est d'identifier
des bactéries qui pourraient changer la
manière dont absorbe le mercure s'ils
parviennent à identifier on pourrait
éventuellement les ajouter à nos
cocktails de pro billettique comme le
yogourt et ça pourrait devenir une autre
façon de diminuer le mercure qu'on
absorbe de nourriture donc finalement
que vous préfériez manger votre poisson
en sushi ans fiché pour avec un
probiotique vous pouvez vous protéger du
mercure
sans vous priver
[Musique]